-One of the things you've
talked about on your platform
that I want to ask you about
is the idea of raising
teachers' salaries.
Because a lot of people have
different ideas on education.
-Yes.
-And I feel like you define
yourself because you're not
saying, "Let's not put more
money in schools;
let's put more money
in teachers' pockets."
Explain how you came
to that decision.
-Well, first of all,
personal story.
My first-grade teacher,
Mrs. Francis Wilson,
God rest her soul,
attended my law-school
graduation.
-That's fantastic.
-I think most of us would say
that there was a teacher
or more than one teacher
in our lives
who convinced us
that we were special.
We weren't particularly special,
but they convinced us,
and we believed them.
And that's part of what led us
to be in these situations
where we have achieved
any level of success.
There are two groups of people
raising our children --
Parents, and it
could be grandparents,
aunties, and uncles...
and teachers.
And we are not paying
our teachers their value.
Teachers are paid 10% or more
less than similarly educated
college graduates.
And so what I am proposing is,
the first time in our nation,
what would be
a federal investment
in closing the teacher pay gap,
which would result in closing
a gap of about $13,500 a year.
$13,500 a year means a year's
worth of mortgage payments
in most places.
$13,500 a year
means a year's worth
of groceries in most places.
$13,500 a year
means putting a significant dent
in student loan debt.
And the way I think about, Seth,
is that we've got students
who are in college right now
who are excelling in science
who would love nothing more than
to teach middle-school students.
But they're looking
at student loan debt,
they're looking at their bills,
and they've decided,
"Maybe I need to go
and work on Wall Street
because I need to
pay these things off."
I want that person
teaching in that school.
And, frankly, I think
that you can judge a society
based on the way
it treats its children.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right?
-Yeah.
-And one of the greatest
expressions of love
that a society
can give to its children
is to invest in their education.
And by extension,
that means investing in teachers
who are right now working
two and three jobs
to pay the bills.
-Well, as the son
of a public-school teacher,
I would like you to know that
she would have blown that money
as quickly
as you gave it to her.
She's a unique case.
I think most people
would be better with it.
But she --
-No, but seriously --
Like, seriously,
I have met teachers --
First of all,
94% of the teachers
in our schools right now,
in public schools --
94% of them are coming
out of their own pocket
to pay for school supplies.
I have talked to teachers,
one in South Carolina
who was busing tables
as her second job
and then realized
in the same restaurant
there were four other teachers
that were also busing tables,
because they have
a passion to teach,
but they got to pay the bills.
I want them,
instead of a second job,
to spend that time
in professional development
and all the things
they want to do.
And so that's why I'm proposing
the first-ever investment
in teacher pay.
-Well, that's wonderful.
I'm very happy to hear that.
I want to ask --
You have a longer --
Certainly a longer record
in law enforcement
than you do as a senator.
It was 2002? When did you start?
-I was elected in 2003.
-2003.
Some progressives
have taken issue with the way
you were a law-enforcement
official over those years.
Do you feel as though
your perspective on things
has evolved since
you first started the job?
Or do you feel as though
your record is sort of being
unfairly looked at
by progressives
who think that maybe there was
a problem with overincarceration
or issues like that?
-Well, let's be clear.
America has a problem
with mass incarceration.
Let's be clear.
The criminal justice system
of our country is deeply flawed
and needs to be fixed
and has, in many cases,
been informed by bias
and informed by
I think a very --
frankly, backward policy,
which is that it has been formed
in a way that is about reacting
to crime after it happens
instead of thinking about
preventing crime
before it happens.
I made a very conscious decision
to become a prosecutor.
My parents were active
in the Civil Rights Movement.
My sister went on
to lead the ACLU.
When I decided
to be a prosecutor,
it was because I felt
that this is a system
that needs to be reformed
and I want to have a job
of doing it from the inside.
And that's why
I was able to create,
one of the first in the nation,
focuses of a D.A.'S office
on re-entry initiatives.
I created an initiative
that ended up being
a national model
around bringing
drug-sales offenders,
getting them into
job counseling and jobs
and, in that way,
reducing the likelihood
that they would reoffend.
And I'm proud of that work.
But, you know, I'm also thankful
that over the intervening
15 years
that our country has evolved
to understand we really
have got to reform this system.
The tough-on-crime approach
to criminal-justice policy
is not smart, and we have
got to take a position
that instead of saying soft
on crime or tough on crime,
let's be smart on crime,
which means, let's focus on
prevention as an important way
to achieve public safety.
Let's also recognize
the flaws in the system.
-I want to ask you
one last question, as well.
I was realizing you won
your election in 2016.
-Yeah.
-That was your first time
serving in the Senate.
A very exciting night.
-Yes. Yeah.
-It was also the night
Donald Trump won.
Was that the weirdest --
[ Laughter ]
Was that
the weirdest night ever?
Was it like being someone
on the "Titanic" going,
"I've got a boat.
I've got a life raft."
-It was really --
First of all, we were going --
We do a friends and family
small dinner before the party.
We were hoping
there would be a party.
And my husband kept grunting
as we were in the car
'cause he was watching
the ticker tape.
-The needle.
Yeah, we all watched the needle.
-And he was like --
He was making noises.
And I was like,
"What's going on?"
And I said, "No, it's too early.
It can't be."
And as the night progressed,
of course, that's what it was.
-Yeah.
-It was extremely bittersweet.
And I tore up all the notes
that I had prepared to read,
and I just took the stage
and I said,
"We will fight. We will fight."
And then I went home...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then I went home,
and I went home
and I sat on the couch
with a family-sized bag
of nacho Doritos.
And I did not share one chip
with anybody.
And I just watched the TV.
Utter shock and dismay.
-Well, I think
there were very few stores
that had Doritos left
by the following morning.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Best of luck
in the ensuing year or so.
Senator Kamala Harris,
everybody.